Deaf people have their own Name Signs
so that we can identify you.
It's based on who you are, what you do, what you're like.
Name Signs are such an honor
because you can only be given a Name Sign by a Deaf person.
And I was like...
I just like, kinda want someone to give me a Sign Name,
but I'm not gonna ask for it, 'cause that would be a little needy and annoying.
She was busy, running around and working.
And our A.D. was walking by
and they bonked heads so hard.
Harder than I have ever bonked heads with anybody in my life.
And Troy was like, "Even I heard that."
So we gave her a nickname sign:
* BONK *
Look, there goes *Bonk*.
It was like two 'S's like, bonking together.
And I was like: No! That can't be my Sign Name!
I've been waiting for a Sign Name for all this time.
And now I'm like, "Bonk"?
Like, for life I'm "Bonk"?
But we gave her a more professional Sign Name:
* S I Â N *
*Siân*
Which is the shine from her eye.
Because her eyes are so intense and capture everything.
It fits her perfectly.